what's up everybody Welcome to LED live
we have a really cool show today and
we're going to be looking at a topic
that it really impacts us all because
paganism has infiltrated our culture in
such a submersive way I mean it's really
nothing new you look at the Bible and it
was like Judaism and paganism and it's
just all over and so really that's the
way our society is today right like
paganism is just all around us but it's
kind of been veiled it's kind of been
disguised over time and even
christianized in certain ways right yes
exactly it's it's been immersive in all
of our culture today in fact it's kind
of like a I hate to pop it but it's kind
of a um Unearthed One World type thing
going on and we're going to get into
that um probably in the next kind of
video over this but it is huge it is
actually infiltrating everyone's life
yeah so we we talk about it a lot that
there I mean any anybody who's really
like a a scholar or just a student of
the Bible in Prophecy we know there's
going to come a time in the end where
everyone is going to be worshiping the
dragon everybody's going to be engaged
yeah and this false system of worship
that looks so close to the truth coexist
kumay you know peace and safety and all
this stuff but there's going to be a
group of people who say no we stand on
we have we we keep the Commandments of
God and we have the faith and the
testimony of Jesus Christ and they're
going to be Public Enemy Number One
because you're not going with the system
why you why you being such a extremist
because I stand on thus sayeth the Lord
and even a lot of Christians today
they're not reading their Bible they're
going to church once a week they're
maybe watching a few videos and most of
the time it's about hey you can be rich
and all these things and so they're
going to be setting themselves up for
deception because deception is so close
to the truth that if you don't know the
true truth you're going to fall for the
deception yes exactly and that's perfect
because that's what we're going to be
finding out is where do these holidays
come from holidays all right yeah
holidays a lot of people have a lot of
questions on this topic and we have have
lightly addressed it so I'm excited to
kind of bring this up and and talk about
it because like you said I think worship
at its core is what this is all about
it's what the war in heaven began over
it's what's going to end and so the
devil's always used this this just kind
of false Worship in society to basically
lead the True Believers away so how can
we protect against that and I think you
have to talk about some of these issues
so excited to dive into this that word
holiday is holy day right yes it is so
yeah it is a form of worship so let's
get into this we are yeah going to
unmask the holidays and their Origins
and
wow that's a pretty this is this is what
it would look like if you had spiritual
eyes and you could see in the spirit
world of what's really going on you know
the movie um they live where everything
looks normal and he puts on those
sunglasses and everything's black and
white but Billboards say like obey
consume and you know the money says
you're God and all these things it's
kind of feel like that sometimes in in
life it's like we're so used to this
stuff we think it's normal and then you
find out oh it's got a really terrible
origin even even like the nursery rhymes
for kids and stuff like they're all
about polio and London bridg Is Falling
Down Yay let's think about it you know
especially like this time of year my
subdivision that I live in it's like
there's these giant like Halloween
things that they put out in their front
yard with like people hanging from like
a tree and I mean that's awful like what
if what if you had somebody close to you
that you know maybe potentially
committed suicide or something like why
do we glorify this stuff it's crazy
isn't it Anton L who is the founder of
the Church of Satan or the satanic
church one of those two um who says that
uh he's glad that once a year Christian
parents uh will allow the children to
worship the devil which is UN Halloween
satanists aren't coming into church for
one day a week like I mean one day a
year you know so it's just kind of
interesting that Christians feel
comfortable to do that but it's not
happening on the reverse
right well this is getting in depth
already
okay so first we have to start out where
things began and that is at the flood we
have the Rebellion it brought it was
brought by the flood it spread through
Nimrod After the flood because you have
to think about this we have a people who
are just rebelling against God in their
ways of really wanting to follow after
their own Hearts continuously and God
says it's evil um but then after they
land landed I don't know if anyone has
ever paid attention to this in depth but
after they landed from the ark you have
ham Shem and japheth and then they um
ham has a son named Kush and Kush has a
son named Nimrod Nimrod and everything
starts from there so let's just follow
that up with the
verse then the Lord saw that the
wickedness of man was great in the earth
and that every intent of the thoughts of
his heart was only evil continually and
the Lord was sorry that he had made man
on the earth and he was grieved in his
heart so the Lord said I will destroy
man whom I have created from the face of
the Earth both man and Beast creeping
thing and birds of the air for I am
sorry that I have made them so that was
yeah
right during the flood that he said that
or before it I should say it's crazy
that like you know God has to desty
destroy a lot of people I mean there's
like eight people out of the world made
it through that experience like that's
like such a small fraction of people and
then it just happens one or two
generations away from there again you
know yes and then we're still dealing
with the effects of the choices that
these people made it's crazy M I think
it definitely is Satan he plants seeds
in our life or in our hearts I guess and
they just grow and take off and he knew
that God had just killed off most of the
world and that he had to work on one of
those Sons their hearts to actually
birth I guess more evil or continue it
so we're going to take a look at what he
did so first his name has such
significance his name is Morad in the
Hebrew I'm not sure if I'm saying that
right but to Rebel the name N means to
Rebel yeah yeah and and I mean just
consider that like was he named and then
his actions kind of follow his
name I mean that's kind of a strange
thing to like call him bad and it's like
this guy's got a rebel he's a rebel he's
a rebel I don't know this might be way
out there but I I've talked to another
friend about this too we think that
Satan perverts everything that's true
and so when you think about things like
oh what's your sign and stuff like
that's totally new age and it's not
anything but is there really something
about when you're born does it kind of
set your character traits or whatever
and like names is synonymous with
character so his name already has
significance here it says the name
Nimrod is derived from the Hebrew Hebrew
verb Morad meaning Rebel adding an N
before the M apparently turns it into an
infinite construct
Nimrod Jeff a Benner at the ancient
Hebrew Research Center writes in ancient
Hebrew citic cultures a person's name
was closely related to to their
character and therefore nimrod's name
fits well with his personality the
person Nimrod is only mentioned in
Genesis 108 and 9 but these two passages
speak volumes about the character of
nimrod the standard translation of verse
9 is something like he was a mighty
Hunter before the Lord therefore it is
said like Nimrod a mighty Hunter before
the Lord so we're going to kind of um
dive into this a little bit deeper
because the word hun in the Bible
actually has great significance as
well so the only two people that it's
referring to here is Nimrod and Esau as
we see the two brothers of Jacob the
twin brother of Jacob sorry from the
story of Esau and Jacob we know that
Esau was not the most respectful person
you know taking his birth right trying
to sell it over pot of soup I
guess um not not only did he despise his
Birthright but to despite his parents he
married foreign women and we know how
much God tells us not to do that that's
right got to be equally Yol yes just to
clarify somebody that might not you know
this might be the first video or
something oh yeah we're not saying like
God doesn't want you with people of
other races or anything you're talking
about like your belief system unequally
yolked like these were Pagan
women yes yeah totally different kind of
cultural backgrounds right yes for sure
um so from this from the vantage point
they're coming from this means in the
hebraic perspective that Hunters are
always seen in a negative
light in verse eight it states that he
was the first on Earth to be a mighty
man the Hebrew phrase may also be
translated as he made a profaning by
being a mighty one in the land to add to
this this verse 9 states that he was a
mighty Hunter before Yahweh but the word
before in Hebrew is uh lift me and
literally means to the face of and in
this case to the face of Yahweh he was a
mighty hunter in place of Yahweh
implying that he rather than Yahweh is
the provider of the people W
interesting like that he provides for
himself or something yes we'll go on to
self-sufficient which is basically the
basis of all Pagan religions yes that's
true I mean they're all kind of tie back
to like you know you have to do this and
this and this which is your
self-sufficiency yes he was of course um
a ruler of many different civilizations
though and he built many cities we'll
cover that as well but because of that
if he's claiming to be the leader of
those cities and such he definitely is
providing for their livelihood he's you
know for their safety he's saying I
basically am
everything yeah yeah and I think they
treated him like that right yes I mean
Nimrod I don't know if you're going to
get into this but it's like he he he
when he died they thought that he went
in the stars and that's kind of where we
started get Star Wars show yes okay love
it yeah this is going to get exciting
yes so let's just cover the last thing
here one final clue in the character of
nimrod is how the Semitic root mrd it's
usually doesn't have vowels so that's
how was stated has been used even into
our own time the ancient semetic root
mrd Morad is the origin of our words
Marauder and murder wow so the term
murder literally came from nimrod's name
mhm W derives of it so if you're a
murderer you're being compared to the
character of
nimrod
wow okay so just for a reference in the
Bible we need to see see where Nimrod
came from for those who don't know I've
heard some people they come up to me
when I've talked about this and they go
well is Nimrod really in the Bible or
where is is he in the Bible so Genesis
8-10 says Kush was the father of nimrod
who became a mighty warrior on the earth
he was a mighty Hunter before the Lord
that is why it is said like Nimrod a
mighty Hunter before the Lord the first
centers of his kingdom were Babylon Yuko
akad and K in
shinar so yeah he had a lot of different
cities that he started so he he was uh
the creator of Babylon yes that's crazy
yes um this guy a bi biblical
archaeologist states that this is not a
positive comment his name is David Dr
David P
Livingston it is more likely a derisive
term of a type a representative of a
system that is epitomized in Rebellion
against the Creator the one true God W
you know and it's like crazy like they
they they had access to people that saw
the world get destroyed I mean you're
like one two generations away from that
they got really old you have no fear of
God like you could clearly heard the
story of what God's capable of doing in
in in the face of rebellion yes like wow
like I mean that that's like a rebellion
on a whole another level I know people
thought that the Tower of Babel was to
escape a another flood and they're just
like hey we can we can escape at this
time you know um so yeah straight up a
city of rebellion even like Babylon you
just say that there there's a strip club
local strip club named Babylon like
that's the name of the strip club even
the movie that came out Babylon yeah mhm
which really was about the craziness of
Hollywood I you're talking about the one
with Brad Pitt yeah just like nonsense
of just absolute debauchery you did a
video on the Grammys which got a lot of
views and it's uh there's Jim car I'm
also here because the AFI is paying me
million3 making me the highest paid
megal maniacal boy King in all of
Babylon a golden idol to worship
kneel before your God Babylon well they
were making fun of reality television
because that's always been like the ugly
stepchild of the like these guys don't
deserve to be here and here we have to
honor these people so it was literally
him going all right you guys get your
worship now and I mean they were
obviously making a joke but there's a
truth in all those jokes well even when
you walked in Hollywood didn't there
there was a plaque that called it
Babylon right oh yeah and and it's still
there I mean if you go to to where they
actually hold the Oscar ceremony um that
that mall that's right there is um
called the um it's like the Hollywood
and Highlands I don't know if there's
actually a proper name for it but but
that that place where the floor is is
called the Babylonian court and there's
a plaque on the wall that says right
there so that just makes me think about
you know if if this is clearly Babylon
is a city of rebellion we know that
Babylon was wicked why do we defend
Hollywood that clearly like calls
themselves Babylon you know it's like so
in your face and yet even Christians
will defend Hollywood against things
that we say about
it yes and it and and it's like I I
guess my answer back to some of those
people is like like I hope you defend
God like you defend that you know like
just right just I hope you're I hope
you're at least making a two-way street
you know like don't just defend the
world and not God Amen so yes
am then so we're going to see
that well there's Babylon for you and a
really beautiful city I wonder how big
it really was oh I know and how it would
have had to been higher than Mountains
for them to think that they could escape
a flood you know yes but all the gardens
going on it would have been so beautiful
right these guys knew how to build
mm okay so as we dive into the meat of
this we're going to visit historian
Josephus he speaks about him from 37 ad
stating now it was Nimrod who excited
them to such an affront and contempt of
God he was the grandson son of ham the
son of Noah a bold man and of great
strength of hand he persuaded them not
to ascribe it to God as if it were
through his means they were happy but to
believe that it was their own courage
which procured that happiness he Nimrod
also gradually changed the government
into tyranny seek seeing no other way of
turning men from the fear of God but to
bring them into a constant dependence
upon his own power he also said he would
be revenged on God if he should have a
mind to drown the world again for that
he Nimrod would build a tower too high
for the waters to be able to reach and
he would avenge himself on God for
destroying their forefathers okay I mean
that's kind of like a very satanic
mindset right I mean that's like that's
like straight Lucifer himself I'm going
to like protect these people I'm going
to provide for them and if you try to
harm them again you know yes I'm going
to build something that you can't
destroy but he can't yeah his um
audacity was amazing not in a good
way and the tower that they built well
we're going to see that it has lots of
meaning as well in the act of building
the Tower of Babel we see his rebellious
heart from Genesis 11:4 it says then
they said come let us build ourselves a
city with a tower that reaches to the
heavens so that we may make a name for
ourselves otherwise we will be scattered
over the face of the whole earth so
Babel in the Hebrew means to confuse or
confound because we know that God that's
what he did to make it stop he just
confused all the languages and ceased
all building what a merciful act he
could have just destroyed him you know
but he's like you know what I'll give
you another kind of chance and the fact
that he came down like he wanted to like
see it I I just think that's cool like
like what a personal God he's like okay
I've heard people have been telling me
I'm going to go down there and and see
it for myself yeah he doesn't bring
judgment on a knee-jerk reaction like oh
that's what's being done sitting on fire
he's like wait I want to I want to
inspect it investigate myself I want to
make sure it's as bad as what they
they're tell tell me it is and and you
go down there and it's like this
prideful you know like we're building
this in the face of God you know it's
like and he still shows Mercy even with
like the flood there like Noah buil an
ark and while you're doing it for 120
years preach the gospel and tell them
that they can get on yeah he was still
that long suffering inviting yeah to see
something miraculous all the animals
getting down there and still you can get
on you get
on very true crazy um where we're going
though and this is an interesting
meaning in Babylon in the Greek it means
the Gate of the Gods I never knew that
for those who want to know where this
happened again God's punishment for this
was that he came down he called it Babel
or confusion for there God confused the
language of the people which forced them
to scatter this Heaven defying group of
people wanted one government to rule the
world o interesting keep that in mind MH
and one religion to sway the hearts of
mankind this was Satan's attempt to defy
God and his authority and the ring
leader of his scheme was Nimrod but God
came down and stopped this worldwide
Rebellion at Babel in defiance of his
command for mankind to replenish the
Earth by confusing their language into
many languages so they could not
understand one another's speech mankind
discontinued the building of Babel and
were scattered to different parts of the
world yeah that first paragraph that's
just like it's it's explaining it's
describing our day we're we're trying to
build a one world religion a one world
government and I wonder who our Nimrod
is today so what did nimrod do in
response to this that is the biggest
question because it sparked everything
that's where everything got kindled and
birthed probably the most satanic thing
ever so Nimrod had a plan to weld
together and strengthen this evil
religious system and so he married his
own mother wow disgusting her name is
samiramis so that was the first I don't
know um incest incest the first kind of
deity type forming um wife mother type
thing like you see in tragedies all the
time this was their playoff of this
pretty much they're patterning that
after the actual events of nimrod and
Babylon so so she was the first deified
queen of Babylon and Nimrod was the
first deified king of course incest was
used here as a bi a basis to unite the
newly false religious system this false
system had its sacrificial plan just as
God had a plan of sacrifice but Satan's
Pagan worship required the offering up
or sacrifice of human beings which is
often the Sons and Daughters of the
worshippers a counterfeit holy day was
instituted in honor of the sun god or
Sunday and this was designed by Satan to
Rob God of his peculiar Authority as the
creator of the universe as designated by
his holy day the
Sabbath Satan just counterfeiting
everything and it's like you know the
ultimate the ultimate demonstration of
something so opposite of God is to
sacrifice your loved ones I mean just
think about how evil that really truly
is I mean you know even Jesus was like
look like somebody would die for their
for their you know family maybe or
friend but for other people like these
guys are sacrificing their own children
yeah it's mindboggling how you could
even get to that space to begin with but
I'm sure they were all just satanically
controlled at that point yes yeah I'm
I'm very sure so Nimrod the second part
that we're on nimrods and Samir Miss's
followers plunged so deeply into sin and
the Occult that they even sacrificed
babies to Satan in their worship of him
creating Bale worship as we know or ball
some people call it ball Bale even Bell
I've seen Bel L you that too um we'll
just need to keep that in mind as we go
on but this became a common practice
until it is said that Shem do you
remember Shem who was um a son of Noah y
he was like a probably an older guy
right at this point yeah he came along
and he actually killed Nimrod cut him
into small pieces as an example to
others not to commit such abominable
sins and not to follow such evil
religious practices wow I didn't know
that they did that in the name of God
did yeah he was blessed for it wow it's
like David you know slaying Goliath to
defend God he walked around the head
think about that like it's crazy what
these guys who did mhm but of course
there's always an action for every
there's a reaction I'm sorry for every
action so we're going to see what
happened with this movement that was
created so here's just a
depiction and this brought on the use of
the Pagan Sun wheel which we will see so
this is where it all starts exploding
here W there's a lot of stuff on there I
am going to just point out a few let me
know what you guys what stands out to
you we'll just start talking about this
real quick well all my life I've heard
the peace sign was bad you know we we
hear like peace oh it's you know it's a
it's a good word peace everybody loves
peace but I've always been told it was a
upside down broken cross later in life I
found out it was called The Crow's foot
or the witch's foot and it's a it's like
you'll see it on runes and stuff uh it's
part of Witchcraft and people it's all
over People's Clothing and everything
yeah it's made to be popular mhm and
just since you mentioned that you have
ones like that where you don't even have
to draw the circle around the P sign it
still means that same symbol it's still
the Pagan Sun here we have the
Babylonian Sun wheel with its eagle on
it and the black sun is actually today
still a black Sun cult where the Nazis
derived their Nazi symbol and then it
became this which that symbol goes way
back I mean you'll see it engraved in uh
buildings and things like in what Asia
and foot of Buddha that's right wow
maybe Jewish kalala it is tree of kalala
we have some other ancient ones the one
with the red and the dots that's kind of
where it went from there and of course
people like to joke that's why we have
the first invention of the
wheel because that's what was on
everyone's mind it was just their the
way they worshiped we have the Celtic
knot down here MH um so beautiful but
you know doesn't represent good things
we have the sign of Horus which is what
that became as well just putting a plus
sign pretty much together that's the uh
Disturbed logo which is always
interesting that Disturbed was kind of
pushing that whole movement of coexist
all religions lead to God I mean you got
the Crescent Moon there's a triangle
there's a hexagram pentagram and then
I'm seeing probably the reason it's on
there is this circle with a plus in it
so that's the sun wheel mhm actually all
of it because you end up having an
overlay of um pentagram P basically in
the middle and your seasons are on the
outside just like in that Wiccan wheel
right there um they over the the moon's
phases and cycles and all the holidays
and the dates and your zodiac sign
that's where we're going up here the
zodiac sign for everything and as well
as the planets that you are worshiping
alongside of it so it all becomes
astrology and meditation and um all
wiccanism and the ank from the Egyptians
it's all the same and like the cabala
the tree of
cabala and we have the Christian symbol
that's the hard part is that we need to
realize
that even the cross was actually the
cross of tamuz and samiramis and Nimrod
had a son named tamuz when she got
pregnant unfortunately from
Nimrod he they birthed a son named tamuz
and he became kind of
their I don't know their infant God so
he was known Nimrod was known as a sun
god samam Miss was known as the um Moon
God and then tamu's I'm not sure exactly
he's just kind of the god of everything
else and they used the the cross
especially in Rome to sacrifice or um
discipline all the criminals on the
cross of tamuz interesting yeah I know
I've I've heard that too that it's like
a pagan symbol and I'm like well of
course it was pagans that crucified
Jesus to it you know if Jesus was
beheaded we'd be wearing a guillotine
around our neck in memory of Jesus it's
weird that we see that symbol and we
automatically I mean you see that symbol
you think of Christianity you think of
Jesus yet it was a lot of people were
killed on one of those yeah for sure and
but it is interesting when you you think
about the connection with tamamo how
many people in Hollywood wear a
Christian cross dude like everybody and
it's like you know you you don't believe
that that's your that's your flaunting
it it like you know yeah because you got
these rappers that are sitting there
like drinking and smoking and the girls
all around them when they're rocking
this huge cross and it's swinging it's
just a complete mockery any sense yeah
that's really what it was I remember
when Roger mono was talking about them
singing hems like out of the Hennel in
satanic worship ceremonies and it was
just an actual Act of blasphemy that's
pretty much what it's there for is it's
just here's a piece of straight in your-
face blasphemy right I mean when I was
obsessed with Marilyn Manson was Gothic
I I would wear a a shirt about Jesus as
a mockery just like uh irony or whatever
you know people knew when they saw me I
wasn't a Christian you know MH yeah it's
that's a hard one to take I I never
thought people would actually do that on
purpose I know that sounds weird but to
actually just blatantly mock you to your
face if you are Christian or God to his
face I didn't think about that well yeah
it's it's changed drastically in a short
time I mean cuz when I was growing up
you'd ask anybody I mean I grew up up in
the Bible Belt the South or whatever but
you ask anybody do you believe in god oh
yeah are you going to heaven oh yeah I'm
going to heaven you know they might be
drinking a beer and smoking a cigarette
but it was it was still looked at as a
positive thing to be a Christian it
means you're a trustworthy person it
means that you go to church every week
it doesn't matter if it changes your
life or not but people generally if if
you found out oh you can trust him you
can buy that car from that guy he's a
Christian you know now it's totally
different in just 30 years
now to be a Christian you must be a
bigot you must be a hater you must be
hate speech all this stuff it's changed
rapidly mhm they've turned it on its
head for sure we have a Middle Eastern
Star here with the yellow and
pentagram and I was really shocked to
see that one because it has a sword on
it you kind of have like the Islamic oh
yeah thing going on so when Nimrod got
killed by Shem worship ceased and
followers of nimrod became very
afraid um till samiramis devised plan a
plan upon discovering that she was
pregnant claiming Nimrod died because
the Incarnate son god wow came down and
impregnated her thus she turned Nimrod
herself and her illegitimate child when
born into a glorified into glorified
gods and deities and so she's kind of
The Mastermind actually after Nimrod
leaves the scene people actually
believed her like sure the son got you
pregnant y yep but it formed a whole a
whole system of worship yep for sure uh
interesting birthday December 25th that
was tamuz was born on December 25th yes
that's what she claimed that's how we
get so wa this is nimrod's Mom gets
pregnant by her son yes calls it the son
God that made her pregnant and then has
okay just clarifying my mind there for a
second yes um so she claimed that her
son tamuz there we go is the sun
god her I'm sorry I read that wrong she
claimed that Nimrod was the sun god her
the moon goddess and their child was
named tamu's birthday December 25th and
isn't that just crazy I mean it's just
crazy that we honor that day I know in
our culture yeah yeah there's no
coincidence that they pretty much like
if you think about when Jesus really
would have been born in the Middle East
MH first of all you don't have Santa
Claus in red you don't have snow you
don't have a bunch of gifts they weren't
Rich enough for that you don't have
reindeer you don't have all these things
probably not even pine trees no not at
all and you have a totally different um
time of year I've heard like basically
in June yeah I've heard it would have
been Springtime for whatever reason they
know that I guess because they were out
in the barn and different things there's
a reason they know because of the way it
was uh
the Shepherds were out and all this
stuff right yeah interesting so it just
seems like to me anyway that they chose
that date because it coincided with the
Pagan wheel already and they just wanted
to Overlay that that one world religion
over everything yeah and so Jesus all of
a sudden was born on the 25th of
December when it was really
tamuz um now now how did that come into
the Christian faith that was through the
are you going to get there okay I'm
trying to like I want to add input but
I'm sure it's going to get it's going to
get there okay yeah um so we'll just
continue due to fear of being killed and
found out samiramis made it a secret
mystery religion as you always hear of
that Babylonian caldan
Mysteries um it was conducted
underground focused on mysterious Satan
worship lies deception mystery of
iniquity illusion and the Occult W so
this is where um we have the birthing of
secret
societies wow from Tam moons yep even
way back then and you can see alcoves
I've I've looked at how um Christian
churches in Israel or in the land that
they were at you can actually tell based
on what they have in the church that it
was Christian or pagan
and pagans really met underneath the
ground like it was just seriously a cave
or some kind of hole and they didn't
have pews they had marble it's always
like a rock thing that's where the
masonry um Masons come from they were
good with their hands um always making
rock
things wow and I'll just throw that in
there cuz we're on it you have the
pythagoreans you know Pythagorean so
they're known for their math their math
is very important to cult World um and
numerology but they also wore like Peter
Pan hat the White and the Seven Dwarfs
the dwarfs all have that hat as well
talking about Peter Pan's kind of like
hat y they're kind of uh well I don't
know if it's Peter Pan but the dwarves
they had like this red like beanie that
was kind of flopped over you'll see it
on like a military seal and stuff too MH
yeah but that has it's always honoring
them going back to that time because
they're one of the first secret
societies wow I I think this is
something that people don't recognize
too about all these characters and
Disney they have these ties back here to
these very dark Origins and I mean it
doesn't take much digging to look around
in that um I encourage you listeners out
there if you let your children watch
Disney stuff look into the origins of
that the internet is an amazing resource
Mickey Mouse's white gloves was a Mason
thing and all the characters
Peter Pan wasn't the writer like a
pedophile or something came up with the
Peter Pan story yep yeah so yeah that's
all that's all out there you should
research it we have a video on Peter Pan
actually you can look that up yeah y um
so we're just going to talk about this
counterfeit day of worship that Nimrod
created with bale worship and Samir Miss
continued with all of her worshippers so
the apostasy began by Nimrod um um begun
by Nimrod found its Zenith in the lavish
temples and huge pyramids I don't know
if you guys realize that pyramids
interesting the Egyptian culture they
like point to the sun I all about Sun
worship right they point to planets and
things uh one of the guys that started
our ministry with us Brandon he um Was
An Architect took architectural School
in in college and um he said that there
was so much Babylonian learning about
even the modern buildings where they
build them how they face them they pay
attention to where the sun comes even
today like all the buildings you see in
a Downtown City those are well thought
out and they they actually study the
Babylonian stuff wow interesting wow
that's incredible huge pyramids
dedicated to the Sun God where men
offered animal and human sacrifices
Hislop who is a um Theologian of that
time as well right about the origin of
sun worship as follows the beginning
then of sun worship and of the worship
of the host of heaven or astrology was a
sin against the light against the true
God himself a presumptuous Heaven daring
sin as a sun in the heavens was the
great object of worship so fire was
worshiped as its Earthly
representative along with the Sun as the
great fire god and in due time
identified with him was the serpent
worshiped who mhm the sun worship and
serpent worship go H and H they do and
fire worship so all around the world you
see people worshiping dragons that's
right the dragon goes there toes and Sun
for sure I mean in many different forms
whether it's pyramids or these circular
discs that you were showing us in the
symbols
mhm yep I me we really see how the the
Fulfillment of the Bible saying that the
dragon will deceive the entire world and
they're all going to worship him yes yes
that's important to understand like you
mentioned the understanding that Satan
masquerades as the sun god the fire
dragon and serpent if you find worship
of any of those kinds you pretty much
identified Satan at the core which it's
in New Age and everything too the calini
inviting that serpent to your crown
chakra me it's like really in everything
mhm man right I'm just thinking of all
the major corporate logos who have
changed their symbol to a sun I mean
Walmart used to just be like wall
starmart now it's a six-pointed sun
that's so interesting BP used to be a
green shield now it's a green sun I mean
Suns don't know everything Dole um all
these like hotels like basically every
major corporate logo is an eyeball a
triangle or a symbol of sun like
literally it's crazy MH that's why at
revelation 1823 talks about the great
Merchants were the were the ones that
were following yeah deceive the world
through sorcery and pH yeah well that's
very interesting because you know the
root of all evil is money yeah the love
of
it yeah these these huge corporations
that buy into this kind of stuff yeah
yeah so they're they're really just kind
of giving like we would you know if you
started a a Christian lawnmowing company
and you kind of made the tea in that
company across or something you've seen
that you've seen like these local owned
businesses that kind of throw a cross
these are major corporations and they
know who they serve and they know okay
they're they're Masons and things like
that so they're going to make their
corporate logo a triangle or a a symbol
of sun or an eyeball because they're
showing their allegiance just as a
Christian 66 yeah that Disney WT Disney
right there but it is an allegiance
thing that's that's kind of key
understanding this so we'll continue on
in um along with along with the Sun as
the great fire god and in due time
identified with him was a serpent
worshiped in mythology of the Primitive
world says Owen the writer here the
serpent is universally the symbol of the
Sun in Egypt one of the most common
symbols of the Sun or Sun God is a dis
with a serpent around it as a the sun
was the great enlightener of the
physical world so the serpent was held
to have
been the great enlightener of the
spiritual by giving mankind the
knowledge of Good and Evil oh wow at all
events we have evidence both scriptural
and profane for the fact that the
worship of the serpent began side by
side with the worship of fire and the
sun man it's amazing that scripture and
secular history
all tell us the same thing and yet
people still be in denial you know just
that cognitive dissidence yeah for sure
so Samuel Baki is also a well-known
writer on historical events and Biblical
times and he writes there is no question
that the existence of the planetary week
with its Sund day d uh Das Solus I'm not
sure if I said that right but is crucial
for determining any influence of worship
on the Christian adoption of Sunday
observance in as much as the sun before
the existence of the weekly Sunday was
venerated every morning every morning
every
morning
um and one more here
Socrates
scholasticus states that the 4th Century
Rome had ceased to worship on the
Sabbath he mentions Sabbath for some
reason here
and they had ceased so they always had
before kept the Sabbath even the Romans
interesting the ones that had yeah
started while Alexandria held its love
feasts or eucharists on the first day
substituting it for the Sabbath as kept
in other
churches so basically they were like
there's all these pagans out here that
are keeping this venerable day of the
sun they worship the sun why don't we
just do it on Sunday too that way we
could all kind of go to church at the
same time and maybe we can even recruit
them in I mean maybe they did with good
intentions who know I don't know but you
can't take a commandment of God and say
h let's just do this let's do it this
way instead right I mean that's what
that's what the error was with Cain Cain
and Abel you know like he was doing
something good yeah Abel offer sacrifice
yeah Abel gave the sacrifice the way God
said to with a spotless lamb and a Cain
gave the best he had which was his
vegetables but that was not what God
asked right exactly we can't tweak what
God asks of us yeah even if your heart
is in the right place God knows my heart
God knew Kane's heart he was given the
best he had but he still didn't do what
God asked right I think that's a really
important part for people to kind of
consider when when when thinking about
this topic and you know you can do the
wrong thing with the right heart you
know what I mean like it's you have to
you have to listen to what God says in
the Bible and do what he says in the
Bible we cannot just take that and be
like I'm going to do whatever I want to
do and and there's a thing though like
the Bible talks about God Winks at our
ignorance yes and he judges according to
the lights that's been given us so if we
don't know any better God basically is
like it's okay you worship me according
to how you knew but once you know then
you can't say oh well God knows my heart
what is in your heart is it in your
heart I want to worship God the way he
asks me to the way he knows how is best
for me in my relation with him or is
like I've been doing this for so many
years it's tradition I just going to do
it anyway and surely God won't mad won't
care like no it's in the scriptures you
know and it's and it says um that um his
scriptures do not change right like what
he says will stay it will stick I'm glad
you brought that verse up about win can
our sins and ignorance but it is our
responsibility to seek out truth and we
live in the information age you know so
there's going to be a lot
less uh excuses for people in our day
and age you know and even if you're
seeing something like this at this point
it's your responsibility search it out
what do you find um and then you have to
make that decision and then you will be
judged on what you know so there's a
study for you if you haven't studied the
Sabbath out look into it you have to at
least into it and we've got an online
Bible school that's completely for free
and you know you can look through any of
these things for yourself amen and I
actually want to encourage people this
is actually how I got into this is one
of the pastors challenged me to look up
tamuz from the Bible H wow it was
directly in the Bible and you just take
it from there and you follow it down
it's rabbit trails to all the different
gods in the Bible and you'll find out
where all this comes from and then do
your historical research online and
everything tie it together so and we
waste a lot of time in our lives just
watching mindless entertainment we just
a world of things to discover out there
you know yep yes for
sure okay so here is where this this
idea of it becoming part of the
Christian world came into
existence the Das soless was evid EV L
the most sacred day of the week for the
faithful of
Mithra Mithra isn't that the the who the
um Lady Liberty is kind of modeled after
a little bit
yes um it is also if you get into the
higher hierarchy of the Catholic Church
the priests and the Cardinals and
everything are on a different level of
priesthood within
Mithra um
worship and you'll find that in
Freemasonry
and and the like I guess so it's really
interesting a lot of the secret
societies have all of those different
hierarchies or levels to work
through um but yes to it was the most
sacred day of the week for the faithful
of Mithra and like the some professing
Christians they had to keep Sunday holy
and not the Seventh Day biblical
Sabbath that's
interesting keep it yes the gods have
arranged the days of the week so here's
acknowledging different gods not God in
general whose names the Romans have
dedicated to certain Stars the first day
of the week they called The Day of the
sun because it is the ruler of all the
stars as it was then so it is today the
day of the sun Das soless Sunday was
always the the most prominent day of
worship and stood at the head of all the
days of the
week following the scriptures and Ten
Commandments we see there is no question
that the Roman Catholic Church fully
comprehends that the scriptures
absolutely require the observance of the
biblical Sabbath the seventh day of the
week called Saturday today Cardinal
James Gibbons fully admits that Sunday
keeping is a Catholic institution based
solely on the traditions of the early
church fathers the edicts of emperor
Constantine the first person to mandate
it in 321 ad mandated
mhm H I think it was on penalty of death
wow if you don't keep the Sunday
mhm so they they they had their their
challenge even back then yeah yeah wow
there was an agenda back then too
Ecclesiastes says history repeats itself
there's no new thing under the sun yeah
that's right the edicts of emperor
Constantine and the ecclesi
ecclesiastical authority of the Catholic
church in the councils of leod deia
decided this in 336 to
ad given also admits that the
establishment of Sunday worship is not
based on the authority of the
scriptures so he comes out and he just
says this yeah and he's going to make a
very I guess bold statement here you may
read the Bible from Genesis to
Revelation and you will not find a
single line authorizing the
sanctification of Sunday MH the
scriptures inforce the religious
observance of Saturday a day which we
never
sanctify Rome's challenge to Protestants
is that if they truly believe the
rallying Cry of the
Reformation solo scriptura they would
reject the Catholic tradition of Sunday
keeping and would be ardently keeping
the seventh day Sabbath as God commands
W you know there's a an Evangelistic
series happening in my church right now
and the the speaker he his name is Eric
Flickinger he uh he's a representative
of it is written a really phenomenal TV
Ministry he he said in all of his years
that he has been doing these
Evangelistic series doing TV pres
presentations and everything he said on
live TV he would tell the viewers I'll
give you $1,000 if you can show me where
in the Scriptures it says that the
seventh day Sabbath has been changed to
the first day of the week Sunday as the
day of worship and nobody's ever been
able to show him from the scriptures
that he's been changed well these are
the people who are telling you we did it
this is when it happened and um
basically to say otherwise is I I've
seen some more scriptures about this
they say to say otherwise is dishonest
saying if you say that Sunday is in the
scriptures you're really just being
dishonest wow and so they're telling you
nowhere in Genesis the Revelation but
yet people will try to say you know they
they bring up certain verses like it
says um what was it the offering was
gathered on the first day of the week or
something Jesus rose in the first day of
the week and that's Paul preaching you
know like Jesus changed it but it
doesn't say it anywhere even in fact if
you look at the um who was it was it
Mary Magdalene and another Mary that
came to Jesus on the first day of the
week on Sunday you know it says that
they when they wanted to anoint his body
yes they and wanted to buy spices to do
so they waited until Sunday they wanted
to do it Friday but uh the Sabbath is
kept Sunset Friday Sunset till Saturday
Sunset they waited and then Sunday they
went and to uh you know and Balm Jesus's
body so they kept the Sabbath in fact
Jesus kept the Sabbath in the Tomb
because on Friday he died he didn't do
anything on Sabbath and on Sunday he
rose again I mean he did it himself and
then you could see that um you people
say oh the Sabbath was there for the
Jews well in fact the Sabbath was
created in Genesis before the Jews ever
came about right for all of humanity it
was created Jesus was created for man
not Jews and then um and then obviously
you had the Ten Commandments and then um
if you look at what happened after uh
Jesus's Resurrection the the people came
into the church right the Christian
church was started they still kept the
Sabbath you know it wasn't like done
away with or anything preach to the Jews
and the Gentiles alike on the Sabbath
and like I remember in one of the
Scriptures it says that that that Paul
was preaching to the Jews on the Sabbath
and like the the Greeks were like hey we
want to hear this message and he was
like we'll come back next Sabbath you
know he could have said hey come back
tomorrow the new the the new Sunday that
we keep you know but it's never in
Scripture in Isaiah it says that in
heaven when we go to heaven we will be
worshiping in Heaven from Sabbath to
Sabbath right that's future and then
also um if you look at uh the writings
of uh the Catholic church and the
Vatican they say themselves that oh we
there's literally a questionnaire like
which day is the Sabbath day it says the
Sabbath day is the seventh day of the
week which is Saturday and then they say
well who changed the Sabbath day and it
says we changed the Sabbath day from
Saturday to Sunday the first day of the
week the Catholic Church admits this I
don't know if we can put it on the
screen or
something yeah like it's literally right
there and and
unfortunately um you know as paganism
entered the church and as c as
Catholicism and the Vatican try to
sway uh the Protestants into a different
direction and do away with the
Reformation that's when the Sunday both
s Sabbath and Sunday were kept and then
eventually Sunday was observed more
happily and joyfully and it was more of
a fun day than the Sabbath day and then
the Sabbath day was completely
demolished until people Christians
rediscovered the Sabbath is the day of
worship that the Lord put in the Bible
why are we keeping Sunday right um a
good point to make though is of course
you're going to keep a day that you're
not going to be killed for keeping yeah
exactly you know what I mean like not
everyone is but most people are going to
just give in and be like of course I'm
going to keep it happily Sunday sure
right but that's how subtle Satan is
he's so subtle and and sneaky and he's
got a long time and he's got an agenda
he's got a plan for this one world
religion so he starts with something
that seems
relatively whatever like like it's not
that big of a deal you know we're just
going to keep Sunday instead of so now
you got a lot of people just breaking
that one little commandment and then it
over time it just gets easier and easier
now you got Christians that are doing
yoga at their Church you know it's just
like a little bit more it's like they
call it creeping compromise it just
keeps coming in you I think a question
that you have to ask yourself is if if
you were presented the truth and you
want to do what God wants you to do what
are you going to do with that
information are you going to say well I
really don't care what you what you just
presented to me and I don't care if it's
the truth or whatever like this I'm just
going to go out out of ease
my whole family does this and whatever I
mean there's you you really have to
respond to truth in the way that like
okay I saw it now what do I do with it
yeah don't just don't just disregard it
because it's easier to Jesus said if you
love me keep my Commandments right and
so um something else that was presented
at church during this Evangelistic
series that was really interesting to me
is he he somebody asked a question well
if I does it really matter for my
salvation if I keep the Sabbath or not M
and and so this pres presenter Eric
Flickinger he said well think about it
this way if it was any other commandment
uh let's look at Thou shalt not kill and
he said what if you have a guy that
comes to series like this right and he's
a serial killer and once a week one day
a week he goes out and he kills a couple
of people every single week for years
he's been doing that and all of a sudden
he's presented with the Commandment Thou
shalt not kill he's like man I can't
kill anymore sucks you know I'm used to
this friends do this my family does this
will it really matter to God will he
really can he just not just close his
eyes and let me enter into heaven even
though I still will continue to kill
people uh once a week it's the same
question if you ask someone if you
present them the story like that and you
ask them will that person go to heaven
will God just say it doesn't really
matter no of course not so um and I
think it's even in the scriptures if you
if you break one commandment you break
all of them yeah I wanted to read that
actually because I was thinking that I
was like well maybe one commandment is
not as necessary as the other but it's
right here in Matthew 5:19 it says
whosoever therefore shall break one of
these least Commandments and shall teach
men so he shall be called the least in
the Kingdom of Heaven but whosoever
shall do and teach them the same Shall
be Called great in the Kingdom of Heaven
so I mean somebody might look at the
fourth Commandment say like that's
that's really not the least commandment
if you break that one and teach others
to do so which there's a lot of people
teaching like you don't got to keep it
this way or whatever you're going to be
called Leisa King not that you're going
to make it to the kingdom and you're
just going to be like a janitor that's
not what it's saying it's saying the
Kingdom of Heaven is looking down on you
those that are in heaven are looking and
saying you're the least but those who
teach them and do them they will be
called Great by Heaven that's looking
down so I've heard people say well at
least I'll still be there that's not
what the verse is saying it's saying the
kingdom of heaven right now is looking
down
and saying those are the least and these
are the
greatest I wanted to make a point real
quick because we're on a good track
right now but it says here I'll just our
a second paragraph here I know it's
large but it mentioned traditions of the
early church fathers and I know that a
lot of people are actually about
studying traditions and the Bible talks
about that there are two Bible verses
maybe we can show that that actually
talk about putting away the word of God
for the traditions of man and not to do
so and we need to heed that this is
exactly what you are doing when you take
up the other religions of the world it's
all manmade so so I I know those
scriptures um so yeah Matthew 15:3 he
says Jesus speaking but he answered and
said unto them why do ye also transgress
the Commandment of God by your tradition
so he's saying you're you're seeing the
Commandment here but but you're going to
keep your tradition instead and then he
says it somewhere else too in Mark
78 he says for laying aside the
Commandment of God ye hold the tradition
of men as the washing of pots and cups
and many other such things ye do and he
said unto them full well ye reject the
Commandment of God that ye may keep your
own tradition and he says you're
honoring me with your lips but your
hearts are far from me that's right it's
a form of godliness but denying the
power thereof to keep the Commandments
the power to have victory over sin to
obey God and all these things and that
was the verse that I was thinking of
that last one yeah yeah you hit it right
on the head we are going to see like we
mentioned we mentioned companies logos
we have the chakra um the third eye here
wow I've never thought of Google play in
that
way Lucifer
wow that's really fascinating the store
that's a dead giveaway you know the the
compass and ruler yeah yeah oh I didn't
even see that before I'm so blind Gmail
before I've seen that yeah Google but
that that's wow I mean if you see One
logo you might think that's just
coincidence but you can see all of
them
right wow I mean the Facebook symbol as
well even the colors it's a bent type of
cross with dots instead of um more wood
columns alongside it that's just so
strange and the little thumbs
up that's brilliant yep wow but here's
where it kind of all comes yeah together
for real because you do you have in this
idea like I said the chakras going it's
the tree of cabala but in the tree of
cabala you can actually plot out the
same Pagan wheel of the
seasons and it's just depicted here as
IHS um is this just Jesuits yes yes that
is and outrightly the pentagram with the
Statue of Bale going on and here we go
here's the tow cross that I was talking
about the maltes cross Latin
cross so it's interesting that people
just The Sun Cross is there and it's
just basically you know a plus sign with
a circle around it most people think
nothing of that mhm and when you do the
plus
sign you have you know not that we've
made it me mean something different
today but you're basically showing in a
way that we've based our construct of
MTH on this concept as
well so it just all centers around all
of it and of course we have it that's
the Babylonian one again oh yeah with um
the squiggly lines let's just get into
this real quick the Squig sply lines are
actually sperm what and the straighten
lines are a woman's eggs interesting so
on the Babylonian Sun wheel you have the
squiggly lines yeah and they always had
that kind of sexual incorporation to I
mean even in the even in the St Peter
square is that kind of like I know it's
like people say it's a ke as well but it
is it's also a phallic and exactly yeah
the Obelisk is a phallic a Yan
the Dome is a pregnant belly it's all
about right fertility yeah was a big
part of what they had Incorporated in
there but you can see the sun wheel
right there in the middle of I just want
to add in here that very few people know
that the Catholic Church Church's
Origins Are pagan and it it's really sad
that a lot of people unfortunately are
and I don't mean to look down on
Catholics my grandparents are were
catholic um I was baptized as a baby in
the Catholic Church you're talking about
the system not I'm talking about the
system not the people and so as a system
as an organization it has a lot of pagan
roots in fact if you look at the um um
the statues of the
Saints originally they were literally uh
Pagan um but gods and idols and Idols so
Constantine who was the emperor at the
time he became a Christian and so
Christianity became very popular in
order to be in government and everything
else you had to be a Christian and so
people became Christians for the wrong
reasons and so in order to make it even
more popular they literally just took
the Pagan Idols uh and statues and said
well instead of being this for God now
it's St Peter and soing this God now
it's this disciple and we are all going
to worship them yeah which even though
the Bible clearly says don't worship
statues etc etc so it really has pagan
origins and it's a pagan system that was
then christianized and that's the
Catholic church that we have today which
is really sad because there's a lot of
people who are very genuine Catholic
people of Catholic Christians who want
to worship God that way but they just
don't know the origin of it it's
interesting I've seen a a presentation
on this and a there was a statue I think
if I remember correctly it was years ago
but I think it was a like a shired curly
haired guy and he's got like a lamb over
his back and it's now it's represented
as Jesus Christ but the statue itself
predates Christ yeah so it's like it
can't possibly be Jesus because it
predated him but here's an example of
we're just going to change this God into
we're going to christianize it you know
christianize paganism a really good
documentary I watched years ago is uh
Revelation the bright the beast in
Babylon by amazing fact
I would highly encourage anyone at home
to watch that you can watch it for free
on YouTube there's a load of history in
there and historians talking about the
exact things that we're talking about
right now we'll put a link to the
description and if you want to watch
Walter Vice 100 hours of onslaught
series like I did you'll learn a whole
lot of stuff we've all watched
it he's instrument on me coming back
into the church and when I when I saw
that guy man I came up to him and gave
him a hug when I first saw him I was
like man I'm only here because of you he
helped your mom too he helped my mom mhm
so solid stuff yeah I like to make a
point the church as it was known to be
in Christians when we say that
Constantine became a Christian that's
why you need to
use because it was not true at all it
was fake it was fake it was fake he
again using the terminology we're
talking about he goes of course I'm
worshiping the Christian God on
Sunday and so when you overlap them all
of a sudden he could say I am a
Christian and March all of his troops
into the water when they're on their way
somewhere and go you're baptized now
into Christianity too wow yeah so we
have to understand that but there's a
huge part in this when you really Trace
back the origins of the word church even
that comes from this transition here we
didn't use the word church ever before
until then we had um Temple we had
synagogues and we would know that that
was really where you were going and that
you were Christian because you would go
to those places I'm not saying that
that's synonymous with Christianity at
all actually or um worshiping the true
God um Christ Jesus but I do know
that none of this has to do with that
and they actually coin the term that's
why you hear the church in a lot of
articles and newscasts and everything
and the church always stands for the
Roman Catholic Church wow people Church
yeah they take that as oh if they're
Baptist or whatever they might be it's
my church it's just all all churches put
together but it's actually the Roman
Catholic church so they get a voice all
the time and then everyone else kind of
goes oh yeah it's my church too but not
really this this picture you haven't
talked about it yet but the this is
Deon the fish God and he's wearing this
it looks like Nimrod or something but
yeah he's wearing this fish head hat and
it's the exact thing that the popes
always wear you wonder like where did
this come from when you see like as a
kid you're like what is he wearing on
his hat where did they get this idea
from it dates back to Babylon yep the
malti cross um I think he even has like
the ank on his on his hat which is like
totally Egyptian you know it's like
there's some some serious like
questionable um symbols that
are yes all of a sudden and he usually
wears pretty much all of them somewhere
on his clothing yeah um the um what was
it sign of horse is also of course one
of the ones we mentioned last time and
it's it's kind of like the Celtic cross
except without the circle basically and
he usually has that on his sleeves yeah
um but yeah it is it's all there if you
really want to look um you will find all
these symbols I've seen the pope
definitely reps the maltes cross and
I've seen like memes that say he's he's
a part of Umbrella Corporation that's a
Resident Evil but even that Resident
Evil uses the Mal cross what is the the
represent the illustration of uh the
steak hanging here so that is what of
course we see usually is Jesus being on
the cross um and didn't always have to
be we always depict it as having a a
baross a cross beam and it isn't always
depicted like that yeah um that was
still the cross of tamuz that they used
to you know kill all the criminals on
and it was that you were actually in
defiance of their laws to tamuz you were
being
penalized yeah I'm thinking of the verse
I mean it's a tough one to swallow but
the verse that says uh consider it a
blessing when they persecute you you
know so to be hung like that because
you're
defying forced Pagan worship was really
an honor for God you know and those
people are going to be blessed in the
Kingdom um one that I'd like to point
out and this is hard for some people it
was hard for me when I realized because
you do you have the sun wheel in the
Vatican Courtyard there um you have the
cabala
[Music]
[Applause]
e
[Music]
[Applause]
but you do have the Hebrew one too
because we always think oh Jesus was
Hebrew he was born and raised into
Judaism they must be clean of this it's
not in there but if you look it's all
the same stuff on there and um they just
call it different things and they still
have some of the same rituals though so
was that did this kind of symbolism come
after Jesus's time before before yes so
even though he was a Jew which was the
religion got instituted unfortunately it
also got tainted which we can see all
over the Bible over and over again they
started worshiping Heathen Gods yes
exactly like we where we began it
actually started I believe some of this
began with its symbols at the beginning
of the flood I mean before it happened
wow and then it kind of got seated into
Nimrod and he just birthed it into more
stuff they think some of this stuff
comes from like the tal mood and some of
those extra biblical or
extra books that the Hebrews and they
use I don't know for sure but I it might
it definitely might um I mean it's kind
of Satan's emo right he's always like
gonna pick apart God's people the best
you know he's going to aim his attack at
the true church so yes what is printed
on the Eucharist the the sacrificial
bread when you go to the Catholic
churches it's always a wafer yeah round
and it usually does have the squiggly
lines and the IHS printed on it
sometimes it's just like the circle with
the Plus in it too yes so you you know
and they I've heard at least that they
used to hold it up to the Sun and bless
it that way putting it over the sun and
the same thing with the eye thing when
you cover one eye and you look into the
Sun or the pyramid type thing you are
kind of
acknowledging that God and blessing them
and honoring them so I've always heard
it um kind of talked about as as maybe
also meaning Isis horse set yes it is
which is very you know time back to
Egypt so that is it's taking the story
of tamuz nimrod Samus and tamuz we're
going to hit that hard in a different
presentation nice but it is their
mimicry of the deity of that because
you've got Isis horse and Seb that is
Nimrod samiramis and TAMU again just an
Egyptian wow yeah so here's where we
need to take heed as it says because the
Lord wants us to know something about
this it says take heed to thyself that
thou be not snared by following them
after that they be destroyed from before
thee and that thou inquire not after
their gods saying how did these nations
serve their gods even so will I do
likewise
Thou shalt not do so unto the Lord thy
God for every Abomination to the Lord
which he hateth have they done unto
their
gods for even their sons and their
daughters they have burnt in the fire to
their gods what things soever I command
you observe to do it Thou shalt not add
thereto nor diminish from it wow I mean
that says I mean that says everything
really whatever God says to do whatever
he commands don't add to it like the
Jews did they added all these things
like you can't walk so far on the
Sabbath and just everything they kept
adding making God's blessing a burden
and don't diminish from it meaning like
don't say hey it's the nine Commandments
instead of the 10 but it's saying like
how do the other people worship their
gods oh they kept the day of the sun
they you know did it this way and that
way they had a festival they did this
like hey let's just make this about a
Christian thing so you got this day
December 25th tamu's birthday and it's
like well why don't we just say it's
jesus' birthday y why don't we just say
these pagan gods are actually you know
Peter John Paul I mean you see it really
happening in our day what this verse
says not to do yes and it ties back I
mean you said it in a different way or
this verse says it in a different way
but basically don't keep the traditions
of man again yeah it's all again it's
how did they how did these men make
these um gods and their traditions and
rituals that they created oh don't ask
about that don't do it is what God
saying it says God hates it if you if
you change a
heathen way of worship whether that's a
holiday or whatever and say oh we will
do we'll do the same thing but we're
going to do it unto God says God hates
it exactly you can't change it out for a
different God and just say I'm I'm
worshiping the
Lord um
yeah it's really interesting that that
every culture has a worship element to
it I mean you would think that like if
if it was it was fake and there's
nothing else out there or anything right
why would we be doing that why would
every single culture across the planet
have this element part of it one of
those has to be the truth you know and I
believe like the devil has counterfeited
this one thing more than anything else
and he has just literally roped the
whole world into to this
nonsense he has yes so this is a just a
bigger picture of that this is the
wiccan I mean this one's I hate to say
it but it's really bad because it has
the planets these symbols mean the
different genders even you've got going
on you of them there's multiple genders
that actually is a thing and you'll find
that that's from Biblical times as well
W man that's a totally different topic I
have a whole like thesis that I didn't
but read on it and you have the zodiac
signs youve got the phases of the moon
you've got the festivals and you have
what else I see the hexagram right in
the center yep in the different
triangles clarify that is not the Star
of David and it's not the sign of Israel
you know it's just been associated with
that but it's really it's a hexagram
it's a very occult symbol that dates Way
Long Ago by predates the pentagram or
whatever lot of the lot of the um oul
civilizations use it as so same as above
as a below whatever happened up there is
going to happen down here vice versa you
know and it's like
yes so just overlapping we need to
understand or start to understand these
are the same things so there you go you
have the hexagram right there in the
middle yep you do in fact have the
hexagram in the middle Sun
yep and it's just walking your way up it
m in a different way Satan has a flavor
for every person you know for me I was
drawn to the dark stuff Ouija boards
tarot cards all that but there's some
people that are like uh I'm kind of
scared of that and he's like oh I got
the new age it's colorful and you know
he about meditation and stretching and
you know he he's got a different bait
for every fish out there all calm and
you know
right um so again the Hebrews have their
entire calendar that that overlaps right
onto it as well and then the biggest
thing is we need to understand
everything is culminating in a one world
religion of quite honestly the occult or
Satan worship and wiccanism so that's
why you really can just end up on this
um which is kind of where we're going to
end because it is the wiccan calendar
it's what we're going to be picking
apart next and seeing how this is really
what is being um told to us are the
holidays that we keep today wow wow and
it's the sabbats which is a these are
witches sabbaths that's right they have
eight of them and it is interesting that
they took the word Sabbath and they
wanted to rebel against it again and
turn away from it so they just called it
sabats well we're going to just give you
a little bit of a taste for this real
quick so breaking it down just a little
bit we have imul what I hope I'm saying
that right but but you'll see that here
on the wheel mhm um you have it's called
in the belly of the mother which of
course that has much more Ault meaning
behind it but like fertility kind of
things and stuff yes and definitely
we'll Deep dive into that yeah but it
literally means use milk for some
reason um but we'll find that it has
everything to do with st bridgid's Day
and New Year's mhm interesting and then
ostara which of course you can probably
hear that what it's what it's going to
mean melding of isar and the goddess
oestra or ostara basically known as
Easter yeah and belain Mayday festival
with a map pole usually first day of
spring known I don't know why but it was
known around the workers day or
International workers day recognizing
mother of Nature and father son
celebrated by planting Greenery and
celebrating just nature in general um
you said the May pole is that the pole
that everybody has a ribbon and they
walk in circles and around it looks so
fun though it does but and they do that
in Europe a lot still um but it has of
course those fertility cult you'll see
it at every Pagan celebration that do
yes um and then Lithia which is right
here
it's juneth which I know people today it
doesn't mean what it means today at all
it had this undercover meaning the whole
time this Pagan religion um type of
meaning and we have just covered it up
with the idea of um isn't it
representing like minorities racial
minorities and stuff yeah yes basically
but it was Midsummer of honoring the Sun
and fire wow so before juneth didn't
have anything to do with that that's
right h Huh
so many how did how did the honoring
minorities get attached to it for more
information and for answers to your
questions on the holidays in depth
please be sure to join us for Holiday
Deep dive part 1 2 3 and four what I
have learned I can't say this you know
conclusively but it just seems like
whatever they can overlay over the
actual dates of paganism they will call
it whatever they want just so that
people stop their work on that day and
venerate that day M interesting that is
really interesting yes so I'm going to
butcher this but lug
nasad sounds good yeah nailed it okay
good the sacrifice to the god of grain
or loaf Mass associated with Labor Day
so again this was before we talked about
oh Labor Day we just want to take a day
off from work it was something Pagan but
then it was overlapped with something
that we can all appreciate yes um and my
understanding is it was already there
and they just went yeah we're going to
get the people to worship this too
everyone's you know Nationwide is going
to keep this so we're just going to give
it a name that people go yeah they're
wor you know they're celebrating me that
I work hard and I get time off it's
interesting that it's called loaf Mass
you have that word mass in there which
you automatically associate with
Catholicism they they do the mess but
I'm I'm guessing that mass predates
Catholicism even because this is pagan
origins are like really old mhm yes they
do you you're right um so maban also
known as Thanksgiving Sam
Hayne um samwin or oh sawin sawin s
thank you or Halloween All Saints Day
and Ule U tide Christmas candle mass is
somewhere in there I think it is
Christmas as well okay but mass is truly
it is a key word there you keep seeing
that over and over that so maen yes how
did this happen with Thanksgiving how
did was this a pagan holiday and did we
now celebrate you know being thankful
and uh the uh I don't know I guess our
ancestors coming to the United States
how did it happen so the witches and
wicens are very usually very handy
people and they believed that you would
start Gathering more wood and you would
have your last Harvest mhm and of course
worship the god of grain and so that
already was there in history they they
had that and then again there's this
beautiful story it might be true I don't
know but that we come to the United
States and the Native Americans help us
with our first winter and we share a
feast with them Thanksgiving for all
that we have right there's always
interwoven stories to make you endeared
usually to that holiday to want to keep
it as well when you don't realize it has
pagan origins all along mhm you really
wonder if those are really true our
history is just just told to us yeah we
just retell that and we make little kids
programs about it yeah I think a lot of
uh Native Americans were treated badly
whether it's slaughtered or ran off the
land or whatever it was I don't think it
was as nice as they make it yeah no I
don't think they had a
a I don't think that had a fresh turkey
and everything on the table you know
stuffing yeah we we the pilgrims where
we have stuffing in our turkey and it's
going to last for Generations well even
that I mean we're going to get so deep
food has everything to do with feasts
right yeah so even food has a
ritualistic perspective to these Gods
wow yeah that you'll find for each
holiday as well
interesting maybe not all of them them
but they do play a large part in each of
them well I'm really looking forward to
the next one because this has just set
the whole groundwork that paganism is
still alive and well all around in our
culture infiltrated everything from
corporate logos to days that we
celebrate and so the next presentation
you have is going to really break down
each of those celebrations where they
originated from why we keep them the way
we do and maybe even what should we do
instead of keeping those days or maybe
keep a little differently mhm but this
has been very eye openening I hope that
it was a blessing to you guys out there
I hope you learned something new if this
was interesting to you please give it a
thumbs up every little interaction with
this video helps it get into the
algorithm helps it spread to other
people if you're not a subscriber click
that subscribe button and share this
with family and friends tell us in the
comments if you agree or disagree or
have any other information we love
interacting with you guys we love
reading those comments and it really
helps us we like to know what do you
want to hear about next next what what
didn't you like what did you like and so
we just thank you guys for being here if
you want to support this ministry you
can do so by donating at Little Light
studios. TV there's a donate button
there we also have merch on lightwear do
shop that helps support this ministry
and helps you to share your Witness by
wearing your witness and if you guys
have little ones around and you want
them to be able to watch Good wholesome
content we don't often promote content
for kids but we're making content for
kids that little like kids so help us
out over there and give us a subscribe
and watch the videos and like them and
help that channel grow we love you we
can't do this without you guys and we'll
see you next time on LED
[Music]
live
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're looking for good wholesome
educational content for your children
subscribe subribe to our new channel
little like
[Music]
kids